The sports gambling podcast is
presented by my bulky dot. Agee,
my bookie daddy g is the official
online sportsbook of the sports gambling
podcasts.
Use the Promo code SGP,
100 for a 100% deposit bonus.
We're also brought to you by odds shark.
They have the latest bedding sets and
trends you won't find anywhere else.
Plus free picks from their
supercomputer and expert writing staff.
Follow them on Twitter at odds shark
and www dot odd shark deck. Uh,
we're also brought to you by bet QL bed
Qlz only app that puts all the knowledge
you need to make smart bets in the palm
of your hand. Login a bet. Q l. Dot.
CEO to download the APP today.
Ooh.
Welcome everyone to the sports gambling.
Pakistan. I'm Sean stack in the money.
Green was my partner in pigs,
right? Real money. Kramer.
It's back baby. I'm a, I'm very excited,
but I'm also a little concerned
about did you punch the table?
This motion pumping in the air ride?
Are you questioning
going into the Vegas trip?
No, I'm not questionable.
I am at 100% I'm ready to go up.
They're cooling off,
season the balls back and we're
ready to do some foot ball.
We got shirts over at the SGP Berge page,
including it's a fucking wheel man and
right football is back and we got a free
low contest.
We got NFL picks and we got bill
bird come in on later on the podcast.
Yeah, we got just so much. God,
my head's about to fucking explode.
We're going to Las Vegas this weekend.
We chewing huge wads a
dip watching sweet action.
We got God just overwhelmed.
It is, it feels like fucking
Christmas Eve Ryan. No,
no female supervision for no 48 hours.
Completely let loose on her
own. And it's uh, it's just,
it just feels like a holiday.
But Ryan, we teased it in, uh,
in the little NFL song,
but freeload contest,
the free roll football
contest is back baby.
Little different this year, right?
A little different. Is it this year?
Be Freer. Old football contest
is being presented by odd shark.
Check them out@oddshark.com
giving him a fall at odd shark. Ed
e, sports gambling, podcasts network,
home to inside Vegas as well as the
college experience and EPL show.
Now what do you do to sign up? You
go to contest that. Sports Gaming,
podcast.com contest dot
sports gambling podcast.com.
Now, unfortunately we do have to
do the pics page from CBS and uh,
so every week the lines will go up
about Wednesday, Wednesday evening,
west coast time. You make your pics and
then I know what you're thinking of.
What are the prizes?
Great Question Ryan.
The prizes this season prices,
we're not giving away sportsbook credit.
We're giving away cold hard cash.
Okay, pretty drinking. I
know what you're thinking.
What are the weekly prize as well? The
weekly prize, whoever wins the week,
you get one item for free
from the SGP merchant page.
But most importantly because
we want to reward consistency,
there could be some freak freak
moments where someone has a great one,
but we want to,
we want guys in there day in,
day out cashing tickets,
much like we did in the
super contests almost.
We didn't actually catch when we did
hit on 60% come on against the spread.
Ryan. These seasoned prize pool will
be determined by the listeners. Oh Wow.
Really? And I know what you're
thinking. How does that work?
The listeners just get to decide,
hold on and get the dental base.
We're going to start calculating here.
Here's how it works.
We meaning a sports gambling,
podcasts, network ads,
shark putting up $2,500 plus.
Now this is where you,
the listeners come in $1 per entry
for the season long prize pool.
So if we get 7,500 people,
we're giving away 10 grand.
If we only get a hundred people,
we're only giving away
2,600 so you the listeners,
it's up to you guys to spread the word,
get everyone signed up and the free roll
football contest and then the season
long prizes first,
first place,
a juicy 60% cut of the
prize pool percentages.
Now I need a calculator again.
Get the database on it. Jeez. 60%
second place,
25% of the prize pool of third place,
15% of the prize pool and
then fourth through eighth,
one item from the SGP march page.
So things a little different
this year and it's not,
it's not roll over credit at a sports
book. Instead it's cold, hard cash,
which I know you guys want.
And uh, listen, ended the
season. That's a perfect time.
Your Post Christmas, your pockets are
empty. You're going to need some cash.
And uh,
what better time than right after the
NFL season and rolling into the playout.
Yeah. What better time? I mean
I would almost rather, uh,
when a week then the season would that
baby whale tee or you can baby whale
tee shirts available the year with the
regular t shirts available that the
hoodies available. Will there be
more shown there? Well, we are a,
we're just looking at some more designs
and we're just going to be loading up
that merge page.
So stay tuned.
The art department's working on
them working over time. And again,
we'll be out in Las Vegas this
weekend so people are hitting us up.
Hit us up. If, uh, you know, we may
have some shirts kicking around,
people are hitting us up like crazy. I
mean, this contest that they're going to,
I mean, we should check in
with Gus Johnson because I
think just the collection
be like the a,
the moment when I was on campus as a
freshman and Brittany Spears came out for
that halftime performance,
just penetration,
a collective nutting of the,
uh, the population. Yeah. No,
I mean people are Jones about the contest.
People are Jones and about Vegas.
People are Jones in about a year.
Everyone's DFS lineups.
There's just, there's just a frantic
energy that takes over your brain.
If you're like me,
I'm just stressed out.
I'm laying down different DFS lineups,
all of which obviously check out the,
uh, the DFS picks podcast where
we give out or, or DFS lineups.
But Sunday morning I'll,
I'll be posting all like DFS lineups
on a Instagram at gambling and sports
gambling packets.
You'll have to show me how to use
Instagram when we were in Vegas.
It'll be great. Yeah. So is it, so Sean,
I've already reached that point. Um, I,
fantasy football got got to that point
where I said yes to two of the people
stopped giving a shit about a team halfway
through the draft. Love it just, it's,
I dunno, I've, I'm stressed
out about this Vegas trip.
I'm leaving in like eight hours,
10 hours,
got a lot of stuff to do before I leave.
I don't get your honey do list. Right.
But you gotta you gotta prioritize trying
to find a dog that I liked this week.
A lot of things are stressing
me out. There are, uh,
there are some ugly dogs and uh,
yeah,
I mean not to tip our hands here, but it
does feel like I'll be ending up with a,
uh, with a lot of chalk
this week. Sweet. Sweet.
Brian,
without further ado,
if you're like me and
like Kramer over there,
you are Jonesing to lay down some
sweet action head over to my book.
You got a g the or the official online
sports book a D Swartz game on podcasts.
That's right.
They got a promo code.
You want to Promo code SGP 100 activates
a hundred percent deposit bonus and
over to Michael Key today and,
and they got the in game wagering,
the custom player prop calculator.
I love that big van.
And uh,
and of course all the lines that we'll
be talking about on this episode of the
podcast are available over at my bookie.
Dot. Aig. So you like, you like, uh,
you like where we're coming from.
You like what you're hearing.
You liked the fact that we were 12 and
five last year, ATS with our locks.
You over to my bookie dad Agee bride.
The wave of sweet cash and a
sup 100 hundred percent deposit.
Phoniness my book, you add a jeans,
it's pretty simple. Play win.
And most importantly, Ryan get, Hey,
I thought it was half fun.
No getting paid is having fun.
Joining us on the line, Bill Burr. Bill,
how excited are you that
football is officially back?
Oh, this is the greatest time
of year. It's Jagan in La.
It's starting to get colder at night. I
love it. I'm actually, I, I, you know,
I know there's all these new rules
and they could barely hit each other.
Oh my God, I don't cheat. I don't even
care if it's flag football. It's football.
I'm sorry.
Is this the best?
It's football into Halloween and
thanksgiving. Christmas. I love it.
Favorite time of year.
Honestly, Sean, it's the feeling I get
when I, when I give myself a little, uh,
abstinence from the old medication and
then I, I get to indulge again and that,
that first like sinking into the couch.
That's football for me. I'm, I'm stoked.
It's back. Yup. Comfort
food, baby. It is so great.
I feel like they scared us a little bit
in the a week two and week three of the
pre season. They were just
flagging everything. Any, any uh,
guy lowers his helmet even though he's
got his head up trying to hit him right
in the chest.
They're throwing a flag and then all
of a sudden week for the preseason,
all those flags dried up. I have
a feeling when it comes, you know,
Thursday night we'll see very few of
those penalties actually called the,
because the refs are just as big a fan
of football as us and they know it'll
just kill the game if they do it
all the time. I think they set up,
don't, the reps aren't making that call.
It's the people up top talent to do it.
This is the deal. At some point,
if the game is going to continue,
you're just going to
have to sign a release.
So if you want to play this
at a professional level,
these are the risks and
they're going to make you like,
they're probably drawing
up that contract right now.
You can never come back and
sue us. I mean, look, if, if,
if the state or the federal government
can put you in jail for like 30 years and
then realized they screwed up and the
only way they let you out as you can't sue
them.
I'm sure the NFL can draft
something these for these people,
that belt, they'll come up with something.
So I think the game will be okay.
Yeah. The same people who drew up
the warnings for cigarettes now,
the Philip Morris guys, they'll meet up
with the NFL, they'll figure it out. Hey,
you just got to put this warning on the
helmet. You know, we'll still be good.
Yeah, come on. It was great.
It did feel like this, uh,
this college football weekend leading
into the NFL was almost a kind of a warmup
or play baby.
Yeah.
Did you watch football?
Because football has been like,
it's just been what it's been all
about man for the last few years.
Like it's just,
it's so exciting.
And then they finally figured
out not to have all those,
like just a cupcake games.
You know,
like I remember back in the day when
you would gamble in like in like, uh,
September,
like Nebraska would be favored by 58
over Kent State and then they'd cover,
it was like ridiculous. Um, but now
there was smart enough where they had,
they had the Michigan Notre Dame game,
they had Lsu Miami that the Florida state
game last night. I missed all of that.
I was doing some daddies labor day stuff
with the family. I missed that one. But,
um,
I I absolutely,
I love college football as much as I
love pro so much to my wife's Chagrin my
entire weekend and this
weekend I'm actually in
Sacramento and then I got to go
to the Toronto Film Festival.
Uh,
so I'm missing Saturday football and I'm
flying home during the one o'clock game.
So this is going to be a lot of
Dvr and going on in my house.
Oh, that's my favorite thing. Every season
is the really football's back already.
It's only August, wasn't it?
Just the draft. What happened.
Then you got the combine and
then you just go, hey honey,
one of the real housewives
in the off season. Exactly.
The Bachelor is a full time sport.
Like you know the NFL should be as well.
Yeah.
That that Andy Cohen show,
that's their sports center where they
get those women all stirred up again.
What about on this plate
when she said you're,
you're barren and you
couldn't have children, they
start yelling at each other.
It's like watching a red round the horn.
Yeah it does.
It does.
It does end the pacing of a studio
show cause they bring up game film.
They're breaking it down. What do you,
you know they have former players,
former bachelor's weighing in turning
point Madden's on the telestrator over
there.
That's good.
That's the only way I could,
I had to like get like look at my
wife's perspective and just be like,
this is just her sports center.
And then I was able to kind of relax
and then I really look at a lot of the,
you know, it's a lot of the sports chatter
out there. It's just so ridiculous.
It's like somebody like me who's not
even connected to it. Just I'll tell you,
I'm really concerned about a
middle relief. Know talking
baseball. It's like, oh,
are you somebody who never played
beyond not getting picked in gym class?
The weird thing is always funny.
Sean's a big fan of doing that with the
Eagle and I do enjoy the, uh, you know,
we're, we're going to win it all
this year. It is a way, it's a way,
because if you don't win, you get all
this crap you guys saw. Exactly. Show,
model, Blah. Then all of a sudden your
win and then the other guy, it's like, oh,
we're easy to apply. You didn't play,
but what do you mean? Yeah, when,
when I wake up Monday and the eagles got
their ass kicked, I'm fucking depressed.
All right. I have to live with that.
These guys, that's just a job for them.
This is my fucking life.
So, yeah, I may dress right
at, at people give you
shit saying you guys suck.
You guys show Philly's a bunch of losers
and then all of a sudden if you're win
every, that's when you know you want
to gain. When people say, oh, we,
it's not we, it's like, oh,
we must've won something that
you resent. Yes, exactly. All
right, well, perfect bill, we uh,
we picked up a couple of games here
to break down with you. Of course,
all the spreads come in from our
official partner, my bookie dot. Agee.
He's that Promo Code Bill Bats for
a hundred percent deposit bonus.
First game opening game of the season.
Atlanta falcons heading into Philadelphia
right now it's looking like eagles
minus two and a half. I think it
opened at like three and a half.
It was up to four when it sounded like
when this playing. Now when's is out?
Falls is named the starter.
Which way you lean in on this game.
Ah,
you got to take the eagles
at home. I know. I, you know,
they're going to be raising the flag.
Every one's going to be going nuts.
Half the crowd will be in that
little jail they have. Um, I,
ah, it is, it's still the eagle.
So those should win this game,
but there's still,
until they wouldn't that second one,
there's still the eagles on Nerd,
but I'm going to take the
eagles at home considering, uh,
nick falls at a pedestrian 300 yards in
the Superbowl compared to Tom Brady's
500 yards and losing which
will never be broken. And Tom,
Tom does it again.
Thank you so much for bringing this up.
I go at it with Patriots fans who say
that Brady had a better game that falls
out.
Brady had an amazing game and you can't
obviously knock Brady's play at all.
But in that particular game I would say
nick foals out played him because of the
couple of key plays fulls made and the
limiting of the turnovers and Brady
obviously. Yeah, Sean's defensive of Nick
full is a passion of mine.
Well No. And then the fumble, that
kind of turned the game at the end.
And on the other side you've got nick
foals driving down to get a touchdown.
Now I'm not trying to
not timeout dude. First of all,
Tom Brady's not a running back.
He's like 51 years old.
If you don't block it,
he gets tackled that one fumble
duty through for 500 yards.
If you're really going to put that
it was our defense. Right fix.
What's the problem on both sides of
the ball? Both sides of the ball.
Nick false came out like it was a
regular season game. He wasn't nervous.
Tom Brady's Tom Brady,
Balsa offenses played great
defenses on both teams. Sucked,
sucked. The only thing was the
eagle sucked. A little less.
Eating goes basically
the eagles made the only,
I think defensive play the game.
I'll up saying listen you started
this shit cause I'm sitting there
congratulating you.
If you're going to say like,
like that is like like some ESPN shit.
Just say like do you
have any hot takes gone.
Somebody throws to a 500
yards and they're the problem.
They they I think they
will kind of offs the
magic. No, I would at this point it's my,
it's probably my second favorite sport
or watching Sean talking about how Nicole
is, had a better game than
Tom Brady. And to be clear,
Tom Brady had an amazing game.
The reason the patriots lost was because
they couldn't stop anyone on defense.
That's, that's what I'm really, what
you're bringing it full circle for us.
Nicole's is gonna suck.
Like he has the rest of his career.
Eagles.
Eagles couldn't stop the patriots either.
They stopped him one fucking to do. There
was like two pumps the whole game. Yeah.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
There's no talking shit about what your
defense did in that game other than we
made one play if they would like, I mean
the offense was, it was the weirdest.
I can't watch it because
it's too still too close,
but I have to go back and watch it.
It's the weirdest fucking game.
I mean at this,
that's,
that's some shit that happens at like
division three high school where there's
like two pumps in a game. He looked
like a big game. It was really a,
it was, it was bizarre. I not start yet.
And it started off with what's his
face is like, like, like crying,
like he's had a funeral
that Malcolm Butler.
Oh Man, what did he do? What did
he do? I guess we'll never find,
I should've known. I should've known
when he was, when they'd better.
Anytime Bella check does that we lose.
So I remember we were playing the jets
at home and Wes Welker had made all those
feet joke.
Rex Ryan,
we sat him and then Brady threw the
worst tasks of his career on that.
That screen pass or was just,
it was like he threw it three yard hail.
Mary went up in the air and there's
always a pick six. And uh, so anyway,
what happened,
man,
I wish that you guys beat somebody
else because I was very happy.
I would have what I could have enjoyed
watching the eagles. Finally, what am I,
because I don't wish long term misery on
any sports fan other than a select stu,
you,
Montreal,
Montreal Canadians fans and
Yankee fence to everybody else.
Everybody else.
All right. So Kramer
said, are you going with,
obviously I'm going to be on the eagles.
The key with foals is if
you give him time, if he,
if he doesn't face a pass for us,
she's going to be okay.
They got Jason Peters coming back and
left tackle. I think that'll be huge.
They get some of their weapons back.
I think they could scheme
up a decent game plan.
I think their defense will play good,
uh, against the Falcons here week one.
And uh, yeah, they're raising the banners.
I think there'll be jacked for it.
I'm going on the eagles.
You got shut down the
vikings, you know, everybody,
you guys just completely
shut them down in the,
in the NFC championship game, if I
remember correctly. So the census there,
I just don't,
that was like a twilight zone game.
It was bizarre because I,
every scenario in my head going over
the game for the eagles to when it was
going to be a defensive struggle,
you know, or, or a low scoring game.
I certainly didn't see 13 yeah,
something like that.
That's what I was thinking and I was
shocked to see them pull it out with the,
you know, 74 points or whatever
scored. Yeah, I mean, listen,
it's tough to go against the, the, I mean
the patriots got runner up last year,
but typically the team raising the
banner, it's a good bet. You know,
the contrarian in me also likes the line,
you know,
the line move is moving the wrong way.
Nick falls did just win the Superbowl MVP,
so got to give them better
the benefit of the doubt.
But what I would say the Falcons could
have that pastor I've shown you mentioned
the past rush, that could be the
problem. And just out of principle off,
I'm of course I'm going to fade the
eagles fan niggles. All right. Next up.
Big Game. Houston Texans at the
New England patriots right now.
Patriots six point favorite.
And uh, I'll kick things off.
I like the pats here, lane six against
his texts and his team. I mean,
one thing that's been pretty consistent
in the Brady Bellacheck era is they look
good coming off a loss.
And if you look at 2012 when they lost
the Superbowl in 2008 they and even back
to the parcels and 96
they came back and uh,
they won 34 13 they want 1710 they
want 41 to seven like this team.
I think we'll come out with a statement
game and really put it on the tech since
that's what I'm saying.
I'm not trying to be a jerk here,
but how does,
how does that have anything
to do with this team?
All those and all of the personnel
from all of that. It's like, you know,
they think they play really good
historically and when it's 70 degrees out,
Bella check I guess. Yeah,
I guess. I guess to me it's,
I don't Bella checks the guy that just
doesn't lose back to back games and I
think, listen, little brothers
coming off a Superbowl loss. Yeah.
Bill O'brien,
former guy in the coaching tree.
I think he's going to want
to put it on him. I just,
this patriots team seems like they're
ready to make a statement at home against
the Texans team.
Do you see it go, well, I
think Texas quarterback,
what's his name there to Sean Watson?
He's coming off the ACL.
He's going to be a nightmare.
He's going to be a nightmare
for us trying to contain him.
And the only thing I like is like,
I guess they have the worst
offensive line in the league.
I think that bodes well for
us. Um, what's the spread?
Six patriots laying six at home.
Oh, they always pick the perfect
number. Dot. Yeah, they're so good.
I'm actually,
I'm actually going to take the
Texans with the points because a,
you have the last year we played the
Kansas City chiefs and they came in and
they killed us,
you know,
so I'm gonna play your game and talk
about something that happened before.
Probably it doesn't matter.
I think everybody's going to
jump on the patch being like, oh,
they're going to be pissed because
they've lost the super bowl.
Everything he just said.
And then the time Julio Jones,
that wasn't really,
you're at a sports bar like me without,
and makes a couple of great catches in.
Now also, this is their revenge game.
I'll forget, they haven't seen us since
we, uh, came back and this, you know,
came back historically two years ago
in the Superbowl against them. So, uh,
sorry, I think you were bringing the
falcons in there for a second right there.
Forgot. And we were
playing Texas. I'm sorry.
Oh, good. Kramer. Which way? Which
way you lean in here? I mean, yeah,
it's Bellicheck just whoops.
On his disciples period. Yeah.
Not much to handicap to Sean Watson would
scare me with that defense. Yeah. Uh,
I do, I am curious to see the
offensive line, but I've just seen,
I feel like we've seen this so many times
where a t and optimistic disciple of
bill Bellacheck comes in and just gets,
gets a shit pushed in. So yeah, I'm not,
I'm not a fan of the Patriots
week one. Yeah, I do.
I do think bill is hitting on
something. No, because I feel like,
and maybe this is again
just kind of a gut instinct,
but the pads kind of play
themselves in September.
They use it as an extended preseason.
Kind of try out some stuff,
figure out some things.
And I'm still shocked that Patricia got
a head coaching job because I don't know
that defense didn't want, you know,
instill a lot of confidence. So that's,
that's crazy that he got that Detroit Gig
y'all can't reminds me of,
when I first moved out to la the
first time it'll late nineties,
everybody out here either had a Seinfeld
or a friend's credit and that entitled
them to some sort of show
runner like, uh, or they,
we get some sort of deal and
they would pair them up like, oh,
this guy wrote on friends,
this guy wrote on sign shop.
I think bill Bellacheck is
to Seinfeld of writers' room.
If you did, if you did anything,
if you will, the waterboy. Yeah,
but he was the water boy. Bill Bella
check you. You don't make a lateral move.
You don't become the waterboy you,
you get elevated in physicians.
So maybe that's why a
Patricia's where we is.
I mean it's so true,
but it sounds like Patricia is just,
it sounds like people are already
penciling them in is a failure.
It sounds like things aren't going well.
There's some weird dynamics going on with
that team. All right. One of the, uh,
one of the Monday night games.
There's the dual Monday night game.
Do a kick off the season,
which fuck it.
Why not the La Rams head
up to Oakland right now.
The Raiders four point home
dog bill. I'll let you, uh,
get things started here. How do you,
how do you see this game shaken out?
Do you look, do you like the Raiders?
What's your thoughts on John Gruden?
MMM,
I'm hoping that he doesn't
regret going back to the 24,
seven,
three 65 life of coaching when I
always feel like when coaches get into
broadcasting and there was good at good
at it as is groupness they gotta be
sitting there going like this,
just job as a joke compared to what?
Compared to what I used to have to do.
But I imagine he missed it.
Obviously they gave the right amount
of money. He came back and made Gruden.
I know he's been gone for a while,
man. I mean, well how many years?
Like almost a decade and a half.
He left like early two thousands I right.
Yeah, I think it's good. At least 10
years. I think we looked it up. It was,
it was before the wildcat. So
put that in perspective. Yeah.
Yeah. 2007. Yeah.
So that's a long time and each generation
of kids is a little bit different and
he's also rebuilding and I saw the thing
on the Ram's head coach where he could
recall like you usually see that
in real sports with Bryant Gumbel.
Like they'd be like, hey a minute, 42,
week eight, third quarter, what happened?
He's like, Oh yeah, we ran that sweep
play. The guard didn't get out, uh,
quite where we wanted him to,
but he got the job done.
He has like a photographic memory.
I think that guy is,
is like if anybody's going to
be the next generation of guys,
it's going to be him. And um, where he's,
where he's just taking the rams
so quickly. I just think, uh,
cause is just starting to put it back
together. I would take the ramps.
Okay. Kramer, first of all. Yeah.
It comes off like somewhere between a
serial killer and rain man and that piece,
he's definitely like, well advanced of
grew and, and, and just just imagine,
I mean I have to deal with
millennials on a daily basis shown.
I cannot imagine John Gruden
dealing with millennials. I mean,
we know why he came back.
We saw it in hard knocks last year.
He still was making a playbook.
He just didn't have anyone to give it to.
He loves rocking the visors.
He's, he's cut like half the team.
I think I saw that there's, there's 31
new players on his 53 man roster. Um,
I saw a great tweet.
The Raiders decided to pay a coach $100
million and not pay their best player 90.
Uh, so many reasons to, I
mean, this is the ultimate,
like, just take the ugly dog,
right? This is the ultimate take the ugly
dog on money and I, but I, I can't do it.
I can't do it in this spot. So yeah,
I'm going to fake. I come on and we,
we think Jay Gruden's a joke, at
least I do. He made a mistake,
he's going to realize it
quickly. My talks, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't normally like to take a kind
of road favorite here in a divisional
spot. I normally like to take a Monday
night home dog. Great Opportunity here.
But man,
this Raiders team isn't crazy disarray
and it just seems like the quarterbacks
pissed off. He's upset that
they traded their best player.
It's a weird move to pull this close to
the season and the Raiders did the 24th
ranked defense with cleal Mag.
You trade a all time defensive player.
Now maybe this line up working
out for them in the long run.
But I think this rams offense,
even though they didn't get a lot of reps
in the pre season for whatever reason
McVay maybe, you know, they use the
crazy analytics and some sports side,
no wig Gruden's using analytics.
He openly challenges analytics,
which I Kinda, I normally like the old
school guy approach there, but uh, yeah,
I'm lucky.
Yeah,
look at that.
You look at the ram season that last
year in St Louis didn't go well,
moved out to Fisher. It was just a
complete disaster. Just think of this.
If John like John Gruden became a
caricature, much like John Madden.
Imagine if John Madden came
back to coaching after like
15 years. No fucking way.
Yeah. I, I think burden. It'll
be interesting. I don't know.
I'm not saying, I'm just saying he
walked into a hell of a situation. Yeah.
He's playing these guys week one who
are just going to build on what the past
two seasons, how much they've
improved. I just think they,
I think they're going to keep going.
Yeah.
The rams have a lot of
momentum from last year.
Not even catching like an east coast
team playing that late kickoff.
You're catching another west coast team,
so it's not like they have no,
there might be more rare.
I mean there's gonna be a lot of rams
fans right now that the bandwagon has
gotten nice and roomy. Yeah. I think it's,
I think a lot of ranch hands going
up to, oh, you know, it's true.
That's also true.
That is such a weird tradition.
The guys,
let's get her costumes on and go to the
game. The foam spike shoulder pads like,
hey, I got to, hey, we're
going to go tailgate.
Let me stop off at Michael's first to
get all my face pain and Styrofoam cones.
The glue on the shoulder bags.
I'm a pirate.
So yeah, they used to look like a biker
gang. The crowd somewhere along the line.
Yes. Starting to look like like a musical,
you know what I mean? Like, like, like,
like for kids, you know? Or
even this even this scary thing.
It's a little friendly.
It's almost like you've kissed.
Just became a cheering section.
Yeah.
It's like rocky horror pictures,
whatever the hell that stupid movie is
meets like it needs like a Disney ride or
something. Like we can only make
it so scary because we don't,
there's something about like
when you have the dad bod
and foam spikes coming up, I love that.
They think that they're intimidating.
The other team,
the other team literally has 300 pound
guys trying to rip their heads off.
But you're up there dressed like a
pirate and you're the one who's be
throw him off. Oh, you're eyepatch
man, you're freaking me out.
There's a lot of that.
The dog pound a lot of that silly stuff.
Like you know, your dad goes there on a
rubber mask, eat dog biscuits. It's like,
come on dad, I gotta go. I gotta go.
Oh, on Monday. I have to respect
your father. Come on. Yeah,
you just helped me with my math homework.
You're not crazy. All right bill,
before we, uh, before we let you go here,
what is a, maybe it's these three games,
maybe it's a, a, another game you
feel really strongly about week one.
Can we get you to throw out a lock?
You know, we are a gambling podcasts,
so what is, what is bill burrs
lead pipe lock for week one,
my lead pipe lock.
All right,
this is my lock and it's not
going to be gambling related.
My lock is going to be
whatever happens this week.
Most people in sports are going to
talk radio, are going to act like,
you know,
like say Oakland gets their asses kicked.
All they're going to be talking
about that John Jacob was,
he sitting on $100 million and he's,
and he's all in one worst case scenario,
one game out of first they're going to
act like every goddamn thing that happens
this son Thursday, Sunday and Monday is
what's going to happen the whole year.
They do it every fucking when Kansas
City came out and kick the Patriots,
as all of a sudden Kansas City was
the fucking team of the future.
And what happened to them?
You know,
the Patriots went back and won the
AFC championship, you know, so I mean,
just don't listen for gamblers.
Do not listen to all of the freaking
out that they're going to be doing when
they feel it. That's,
it's just, I don't know,
they always act like the fucking sky is
falling or Jesus just came back after
every single game.
You know what I mean?
You look at some of the teams that started
to get destroyed, missed the playoffs.
And that's a great,
you know,
advice especially for gamblers because
a lot of times you see one week and then
complete crazy overreactions and
we always talk about that week too.
When you're picking your games,
don't overreact to that week one.
If you had a strong feeling or yeah,
whatever you,
you were really high on the team.
It could just be one bad game.
Don't totally throw out your
shit by low Sean. Bye. Hello.
Exactly. Look for the look for
that overreaction spread sheet.
They can jump on that.
Tons of line value there and of course
you can head over to my bookie. Dot.
Agee to take advantage of that
potential line value either week,
one week to live betting prop bets. They
got it all in gateway during my bookie.
Dot. Agee. Use that Promo Code Bill
bets for a 100% deposit bonus. Bill,
appreciate calling in man and uh,
we'll talk to you soon. Thanks dude.
All right guys, go patch. I'll see you
uh, later. Good Times with uh,
Bill Burr. Of course. Check out
bill burn Monday morning podcasts,
one of the best south there,
and speaking of one of the best,
one of the best bet in mobile apps
and Spec you well listen in this game,
Ryan, in this game of finding
picks and making picks,
giving out free picks, you can never
have one thing and that's too much data.
You can net, you can't have
enough beck UL, they got it all.
They got you want to track line movement,
they can help you out.
Do you want to see which team the
public is backing that Kewill's got you
covered. You want to see some of the
trending bets of the day at Spec QL.
You want to calculate your return
on your investment. Ryan Beck,
UL has got you covered.
It's free to download for your apple or
android device. Head over to Beck Ql, dap,
CEO and download the APP.
The only app you need to make you smarter
when it comes to bed.
Beck Que el Sobrante by the makers of
Roanoke QL been leading daily fantasy
optimizer Tressa by over
100,000 DFS players that Q.
L. Dot. C. O Kramer. Let's do it.
Oh, Sean, have you stretched?
You Ready? I might pull a hand.
Listen, we've had all summer. Um,
although it's funny all summer to look
at these lines and yet so much has
changed in the last couple of weeks even
since the last time we talked about it.
So I mean, Sean, let's, should we just,
should we just dive in
or are we just making
sex now? Yes. Alright. Well,
Thursday night, the tradition,
like none other,
the Superbowl winner in this case,
the Philadelphia Eagles hosting the
Atlanta Falcons for a revenge spot
potentially for the falcons.
Suddenly with Carson Wentz out,
the falcons are laying a
point in Philadelphia. Uh,
even I questioned this minus
one 20 on the money line
plus 100 for the eagles.
45 is the total.
We did mention a different spread.
Yes. When we just talked to bill,
it was the night before
and it was two and a half.
Now the Philadelphia Eagles are
home dogs have had the, I mean,
do you remember the dog mass? You
remember lane chats, you remember,
you remember Chris Lung, you remember
that this team was disrespected.
And you remember how they responded and
you're going to make them a home dog
once again.
What is Atlanta done in the off season
that makes you think they're just going
to come in and blow the doors off?
Yes.
Carson Wentz is not at the helm
and that hurts their office.
But you still have super bowl MVP.
Nick falls at the hell.
I mean, yeah they are
missing now. Shawn Jeffery.
But you know what they have
that they didn't have last time.
Jason Peters and Jordan Hicks leading
players on both sides of the ball.
You got j a j healthy
where you are you preparing cause when,
when Atlanta was the dog, I,
I enjoyed that side of it.
I think it's going to be a close game.
Uh,
at two and a half I would
be fine taking the falcons.
But I think at a point there
gets to a point where it's like,
well and maybe I just had time to
think about, maybe I reminded myself.
Oh that's right. It's Matt Ryan. Oh,
Matty ice on the road. I know he, he's a,
he's a cool bro who likes to drink and
natural ice and he's from Philadelphia or
some shit like that.
But
I, then I remember, oh, it's the
falcons and they're going outside to a,
granted it's not going to be cold
or anything, anything like that,
but may actually be human. It's
going, they're going outside.
They're going to be playing a,
just a super savage crowd,
savage.
And we wasn't one fucking Superbowl and
this is the game where they're raising
the banners and you were to come in.
You're not,
you're not making the Superbowl
champs a favorite at home.
That is the definition of disrespect.
Do you kidding me?
Yeah. So, oh, all of that being said like,
I really want to take the
falcons here, but there's a, I,
uh, nick falls is, it's
so hard to do. Hard to
do this with nick folds doesn't look good.
No.
Nicole's doesn't look good
in the preseason. Right.
This guy shows up in big games and
this game at home is a big game.
Now what's the key to the nic fall?
It's the key to Nicole's is giving him
time to throw the book football with
Jason Peters in there who didn't play
all preseason looks 100% they're going to
have time to throw the football.
They're going to scheme up.
I mean if you want to play,
if you want to talk about fantasy j a
Gi I think could have a big game because
they're going to be running screens.
They're going to be getting
him going in the first half.
That's going to loosen up the Atlanta
defense and really I think this game is
just going to come down to
Philly's defense playing
really well and I like what
they've done. Yeah, Timmy Tim journey guns
out, but they blood, they brought it in.
Hello? D Nata Michael Bennet, that
defensive line. Derek Barnett,
second year, he's looking better
brain and Graham is fired up.
Fletcher Cox said he's going to try and
be the defensive player of the year.
He'll looks,
you want to talk about pre season
that guys was just fucking destroying
offensive lines long.
Cox and Chris long still looks good.
This past her.
She's going to get the Atlanta Falcons
and Jordan Hicks being there really helps
them app. I do think not having natural
Brad, their hurts, their run defense,
but this team shows up. They
defend the, the trophy at home.
It's going to be a nightmare for the
Atlanta Falcons who didn't look great in
the pre season. They can say
the eagles look rusty, but the,
the falcons didn't look right.
I just think this is a tough
spot for this falcons team who,
Oh and two against the gym shorts,
defense and I think a Thursday night
they make it. Oh, and three. I got it.
It'll be a competitive game. I
got it. Like 2117 eagles. Yeah,
I mean week one is not,
is not the week to get into a bunch of
trends or data because it's the start of
something new and you don't have
a sample size. Sean, this is the,
no,
it's,
it's a, it's appropriate. It's, this is
the ultimate time where you, you don't,
you don't, don't, don't try to overthink
it. Um, I think there's a lot of reasons,
but look at, just look at the slate.
How many home dogs do we have? Right?
Cleveland, you want to compare
that Superbowl champs to Cleveland?
What's funny is the
Raiders are a home dog.
You want to compare them to the Raiders.
What's funny is I'm about to pick the
eagles and you're getting very defensive.
Not, no, I'm mad at the lines makers.
I mean, I guess I'm not mad at him.
If my bookie daddy wants to give away
their money, then that's their choice.
This isn't the line. They opened it where
it opened and now it's being bet. Yes.
That's what's happening here. Uh, I
will go against this, this action.
I will middly.
I did Bennett when it was at Philly
minus four because I was sure that Carson
Wentz is going to play and I thought I
was getting a great number. So again,
probably probably worth waiting
on these lines, but, well,
not if you get on the right side,
like say giants plus four,
but we'll get to that
later. Yeah. I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna fade this line movement.
I'm going to fade the, uh,
the public opinion and uh,
yeah.
Gimme gimme Philly as as gross as it is.
Shawn,
I gotta take Philly Thursday night
raising the banners and everyone,
everyone thinks about that
patriots chief's game last
year as all the defending
champs got whooped at home.
But that is a first off a that that was an
anomaly.
You got Andy Reid opening opening day,
which is you want to talk about trends
that actually matter when Andy Reid has a
long time to prepare, he is a, he is
a good coach. He coaches them up. So,
and that I think was more the anomaly.
If you look at the previous
years showing shown 80%,
80% of the cash, please say
falcons. Please say falcons.
70% of the tickets on the falcons.
[inaudible] I felt,
I felt, I felt a little nervous, but
now I feel much better. All right,
let's should we move on to Sunday shown?
I can talk about this game all day.
I know you can Sunday 10:00 AM kick it.
I feel you will be in the
beautiful Oh, West Gate. Um,
confirmed it is free again. Like
march madness. Yeah, there was a,
there was a little hiccup
there with their formula,
but we will be in the Westgate ballroom
where they have a just movie screens,
size fires going in and out. Sorry, I'm
a little tipsy. A little fired up. Right?
Yeah, I mean, so uh, I apparently,
I don't know how true this is.
Unconfirmed sources have told me that uh,
apparently it didn't go over well when
they charge for seats during March
madness. So they're, they're
going back to making it free. Uh,
it is definitely a great place to check
out. Games were not being paid at all,
but no, they should pay us 10:00 AM one
of the games that give me a drink ticket.
Come on man. One of the teams that
will definitely be off to the side.
One of the games that will be off to the
side is this one seems to happen every
year. Pittsburgh Steelers with I guess
without Levy on bell at this point.
It does appear that way. He's, they're
heading to Cleveland where this line open.
Sean, I think. I think
what six and a half.
It's come all the way down to four plus
one 75 for the browns minus two 10 for
the Steelers. 46 is the total. So,
so Cleveland money is pouring in.
Yeah. You know the sharps love
them some by the way, Jackson,
one in 31. What more do you
need to see, by the way,
why is it that the GM or the head coach
weren't doing the cuts for the Cleveland
Browns? And did you watch the latest,
sorry, why did they have this assistant?
He was like the assistant GM looked
like Bill Simmons and he was so nervous.
So yeah, it's uh, it's time to
have that conversation. You know,
it's a tough business.
You're going to be great.
Be a man and look them in the AG. Oh, hey
you, you played, you played hard. I mean,
I appreciate it. Or just say, hey man, I
appreciate you showing up. Pest and luck.
Shake his hand. They realize it's the
NFL. You don't need a caudal. Again,
Rhone Nfl, it's, it's super awkward.
It's hard to watch and shows a
huge accident is not a good coach,
has no control of the team,
and they haven't even decided
who's starting at left tackle.
He wouldn't answer that question.
The teams in disarray now tie Rod Taylor
Ryan, who you have a hard on for. Yeah,
he can limit the turkeys are great.
I think he's a great quarterback action,
right, and you're, you're, you're
hokey. Love is making you crazy.
He's a bottom 10 quarterback. Whoa.
Oh, I'll take that bet right now.
I don't know how we quantify this movie.
I'll take that,
but he's not a thought of qualifying
him wins. That's how we quantify it.
He made the fucking playoffs last year.
Shawn,
the every argument you use for nick folds
just, I mean, tie Rod, we'll come on.
Dragos is so much the buffalo is not a
playoff team with nick folds last year.
Dude, you're crazy. No, it's just
crazy. When when teams are bad,
they need a quarterback. They can
give them a little, a little bit,
a little breathing room. Listen,
this isn't a, this isn't a statement.
Cleveland right here. You don't
like Cleveland as a home dog shot
one in 31 I'll, I'll
say that all day. Yeah.
Jackson one to get the fuck out
of you. I'm so glad. Love yet.
But I was not playing this levy on
bell's not worth two and a half points.
No. And if you want to talk
daily fantasy or any fantasy, uh,
Connor, the backup, I think this,
I mean if you listen to the,
how pissed off their o linemen are,
I think they're going to be motivated to,
to show that they don't need levy on pal.
I think this could be a statement
game and it goes deeper than that.
Connor local kid cancer survivor.
Oh come on.
Came back in college.
I mean it and,
and honestly like when he was in app hit,
like he looked through your first round
NFL running back. So I have no dad.
He could step in.
I it a couple of day again.
I'm not getting too deep into this
game. Let's Fade Hugh Jackson. Yes.
And let's not apply two and a half
points of line value to loving on bell.
It's a simple formula. Does this line
so on Pittsburgh, does he get the three?
Yeah,
Tommy. God Damn, if that gets the three
trouble. All right, well we're a,
I feel like we're chalky cause we took
the eagles but they're not actually chalk.
Anyway,
moving on up to the space ship where the
Minnesota Vikings are hosting the Jimmy
g, the very handsome Jimmy g
led San Francisco 40 niners.
The vikings are laying six and a half
points minus two 75 on the money line plus
two 25 for the 49 there's 46 is your
total Zimmer said Dalvin Cook is full.
Go.
Okay.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Don't
you love this Minnesota team?
Like isn't this a classic like I can't
wait. I mean I know you weren't as high.
I'm going to say actually you
weren't quite high in Minnesota.
You had them winning.
I liked this Minnesota team.
We've always talked about Zimmer
gets the most out of his guys,
especially on the defensive side of the
ball. Do they have a shutdown corner?
They have a pass rush and they, they
went out and got a quarterback that sure
it will make them higher variants
this year. But what did I say?
Well we broke down the NFC north.
They are going to destroy people at home
that whatever they did in that building,
they built themselves and amazing home
field advantage. And on the flip side,
San Francisco as a team,
I've been itching to fade and this
should be seven points period.
It's on the wrong side of seven.
While you're, no you're not.
It probably should be Ryan.
But I'm going to go, listen,
I brought two pens out here so I can
throw one at you. What are you doing?
Here's what I'm doing. You, you're, you're
searching for a dog aren't, you know,
I would never do such a thing.
It Minnesota feels a little too easy.
And if you remember
Kirk cousins last year,
opening day at home against the
Philadelphia Eagles as a favorite,
didn't pull it out and even turn the
ball over a couple of times. One,
including a defensive touchdown,
which helped me a when
$200,000 in money or maker,
so which I witnessed at the
uh, west. Congratulations Sean.
I don't know if I've ever mentioned
on the podcast, I think this game,
here's what I think of this game.
If you've watched that San Francisco team
last year and even during Jimmy, Geez,
we're on where they went,
five and o or whatever,
which I I overall for the season I'm
looking to fade San Francisco and get on
Minnesota.
However,
situationally I think
this could end up for me.
This game feels like Minnesota gets out
to a big lead and Jimmy g racks up some
garbage yards and some garbage points.
This to me feels like one of the few
games on the slate where the spread will
matter.
Our Buddy Christian Pina from inside
Vegas points out how often the spread
doesn't matter.
I'm going to make a bold prediction and
say this is a game where the spread will
matter. This actually to me feels
like a three or four point game. Now.
I went into the season thinking, Hey, I
want to go against the 40 niners a lot.
I think they're a little over hyped.
Smart. I'm going to take him here,
but this is where you sell the
stock because it's at its highest.
It's never going to be highest
or higher than when when they,
before they play games,
because this team is not going to be good.
I don't think they're ever going to be
that good. The stock is at a tie point,
sell, sell. So I'm buying
baby for this particular game.
Jimmy Giana dome. He'll be able to move
the ball enough to keep them competitive.
Obviously I'm worried about Jerick
Mckinnon not being there because it seemed
like Shanahan had a hard on for him.
Yeah.
I think Shanahan schemes enough
to get them to cover again.
This is not going to be in my lock or my
dog. Ma, you're backing off it already.
No,
I'm not backing off at it.
Slowly walk over and just know
a game where I don't feel, uh,
listen, I, I know they
opened the season, uh,
against the saints last
year and beat them by 10.
Like to me this is a no brainer there.
They were so good at home. It's just that,
that's all I see.
I see what you're doing.
I know you're trying to fill some dogs
out on that card over there. Yeah.
I just moving on,
Sean,
your boy Andrew Luck and
the Indianapolis Colts,
they host the Cincinnati Bangles
culture minus two and a half.
Definitely see some threes out there.
I liked the two and a half
minus one 50 on the money line.
Cincinnati plus one 30,
48 and a half is the total.
Been hearing a lot of chatter about how
Cincinnati is becoming a darling pick
week one, uh, w w w what
am I missing here, Sean?
Well listen,
Cincinnati is the,
I'll give them the super bowl
for square sharp of the year.
A team because everyone who
fancies themselves a handicapper,
as I'm seeing stuff that you guys
aren't seeing in the Cincinnati Bangles,
what I'm seeing is a guy like Marvin
Lewis who consistently disappoints,
right?
Five and 11 is past 16 road games.
He's a guy who's not
going to win on the road.
And listen,
sometimes you can overthink these things
when it comes to penny on the NFL.
And sometimes you just have to ride a
trend like Andrew luck being the second
best quarterback against the spread.
You know why?
Because the guy just figures
out how to win fucking games.
It doesn't need to get more
complex than that. Now what was it?
What were the cults?
Greatest weakness in the Andrew
Lakira and that was coaching.
Horrible coaching except
for when our buddy, um,
uh, areas was there. They had a good run,
there were well coached then Pagano
not a good coach and they had horrible
offensive line play. That's why Andrew
luck had to take a season that half off,
cause he got the shit kicked out of them.
Now they got Quinten Nelson,
he's pulling out of the guard spot.
He's dominating the offensive line.
He's moving the line now is,
is Andrew luck a little scared to
go deep to Tui Helton? Maybe so.
Maybe not. I think they roll
coverage to t by Hilton and again,
I've said it a million times
in the daily fantasy podcast.
I think Jack Doyle has a big game
against the spangles defense.
Now the contrarian is like, oh, indie's
defense their dog shit, they're at home.
But I think in his defense
is enough to keep them in it.
This is a game you want Andrew Luck.
This is the game.
Now maybe you fade him week two,
week three where the adrenaline
where he's not playing at home,
whatever the situations are.
I haven't even looked at their schedule,
but this seems like a spot
where Andrew luck shows up.
He comes out and says, Hey, I'm back. Uh,
I mean I,
maybe I'm not buying Cincinnati like
some other people and may maybe.
I remember like the crowd is going to
be so juiced up to see Andrew luck and
they had a year of Jacoby percent.
Come on. Maybe my theme here is like,
just like much like Matt Ryan just got
paid and has to go outside and hard a
difficult environment.
Andy Dalton is going into a difficult
environment and we know what Andy Dalton
is, don't we? Yes, it's,
it's a mediocre and less than
quarterback. And like our buddy, a doctor,
Chao at pro football doc mentioned of
the quarterbacks coming back from injury.
Andrew Luck.
He said he was the safest play.
He was the guy that he thought was the
most healed and that's all I need to hear.
You're giving me a healthy Andrew
luck less than three points.
This is a game he shows up in wins.
Yeah. And and Oh, by the way, oh,
I know.
Teams aren't,
no team would be looking ahead
after week one, but they got,
Cincinnati is going to hit the Baltimore
after this. So division division game.
Are we really? Are we on the same fucking
picks? No, I had the 40 niners right now.
Thank God. Yeah. Gimme the colts. I'm, I'm
back. I'm all in on Andrew luck this year.
30 to one MVP.
Maybe I shit.
Next up. Oh, what a shit fest.
This is going to be buffalo led by Mr
Peterman. They head down to Baltimore.
Baltimore is laying eight points
minus three 40 on the money line.
Buffalo plus two 70 40
and a half is the total.
You know what this is Sean Circle it.
This is the ugly,
the ugly dog or the week
of the ugliest dog. Uh,
God, I mean, can can you back? He can't
throw five picks and a half again. Kenny.
Kenny. I mean you would think you would
regress from five picks and a half,
but either way, I'm not
taking buffalo. I like,
I like buffalo situationally.
Normally I don't think they're
going to be quite as bad.
But I think part of that,
them not being as bad as them
getting Josh Allen in the lineup.
So it may take a couple of
games for them to do that.
There's no line value here.
And taking Baltimore because they opened
up and like minus three and a half.
Everyone saw how good the
ravens kind of our as a team,
Joe FLACCO has a fire lit under his ass.
Harbaugh's still solid coach.
I like Baltimore to win the division. I'm
going to take them at minus eight. Oh,
really? You're laying these
points? I don't like it, but
I'm going to have to, uh,
to me this is just the, again,
I'm not going to overthink it.
There has been a lot of line movement
here and while it does seem like buffalo
could be horrible,
horrible dog shit,
I see 92% of the money on the Raymond.
I see 92% of the money on a ravens team
led by Joe Flacco laying more than a
touchdown. Give me the dog,
Shawn. This was my attempt to Doug
and listen, I, I see where you're
coming from here, but it's so obvious.
Peterman socks, other no way. Come on.
Do you want make it is a good coach.
You don't see this as like this.
This is going to be a classic,
like they kick a field goal
to win by five. I mean,
I don't completely disagree.
Baltimore's probably not one of
my strongest plays at minus eight,
but I'm going to fade Peterman on the
road. Next up, Shawn, it's taking a road,
Peterman play. I'm taking a, well
maybe Alan gets a good, how many,
how many picks before Peter
was bold and we see Josh Allen,
I may let me head over to my bookie
and get some end game wager cause I,
I like that kid. I just, I I wonder,
I wonder about this number with Joe
Flacco. I think again the theme here,
I think some like,
like a bunch of non non football playing
months have happened and all of a
sudden we have a different
perception of Joe Flacco like that.
He's worthy of laying this many points.
Get the fuck out of here. Next up Sean,
we have,
I don't know much anticipated Tom Claflin
revenge prevents Jacksonville heading
into New York, laying
the field goal. My minus
minus three minus one 20 minus one 65
on the money line for Jacksonville plus
one 40 for the giants.
43 and a half is the total.
I mean I we, this was a line that I gave
out in the summer of giants plus four.
Yeah, it's moved to a point
that's probably smart movement.
I think this line is right where
it probably needs to be. Ah, Ryan.
Am I going to take Blake Bortles as a
road favorite? You Bet. Oh my goodness.
You Bet. A, because tag
God hates jags. Sean.
God hates Jags,
but God also,
God also hates poor offensive line play.
You are,
you're punching your
ticket to Saks and ville.
This defensive line does not fuck around
and your offensive line is a mess.
I think it's going to be a
bit of a problem. Sean, who
do they play next week? Who?
Who? Who? Who is the worst team the
Jacksonville could have on deck check.
Seville has no rivals,
but who's the worst team that they
could have on deck for the Patriots?
They play the Patriots week too. At home.
At home. Alright, possible. Look, ed spot.
Conference roads. But you can't
look ahead. Wordles on the road.
Listen, it's a bad formula. And at
four I'm thinking about it much more,
but at minus three, give
me the Jags, the giants,
Ryan who explained to me the cornerback
structure, the New York. Jesus Christ.
Okay, so you have to Norris Jenkins.
Yeah, that guy's a player. Right?
Or I'll give him that Isla apple
disaster of a second. Too salesy.
He's been wanting to battle players.
Land in Collins has his back.
He's really committed to the team.
Who is Dante?
Deon is the guy that you and all these
other fucking talking heads that want to
talk shit about the Joe Dante. Deon. It's
going to come in and play the slot a,
he's a baller.
Okay.
I don't really care Shawn.
Okay. I know you don't care,
but people have money on the Kootenays
out with a high ankle sprain.
That's the more concerning thing.
Evan Ingram concussion. He's back.
He's practicing. I just want
to see the offense. Shawn,
I want to see Beckham healthy. Hey, it'll
be, it'll be fun. There'll be a co giants.
I'll have a couple of big plays,
but I think eventually the Jags,
the defense will be too much.
You want the hot tag? Sure.
Barclay goes for over 102 touchdowns.
All right.
I mean the jags defense is really good.
I run events is not okay to
take stands and a hundred yards.
I'm saying that's the hot
take shall. Okay. All right,
well that's the take he just gave.
Keeping the jags minus 30.
I'll take the giants and this is where
I point out even though they were the
number one defense in the league last
year according to Dv away shown 27th
against the run. So it's definitely
the way to exploit them in the,
this new revamped mauling offensive
line of the New York giants.
It's going to come out and smash
some heads. Next up, Shawn Tampa,
the Jamis Winston lists Tampa Bay
Buccaneers led by Ryan Fitz Fitzpatrick.
They head down to the Dome in New Orleans
where New Orleans is laying 10 minus
five 20 on the money line,
three 95 for the bucks,
49 and a half is your total.
That total seems low.
I know it's high but it's 49 and a half
second highest total on the board, uh,
tied with the Rams Oakland
game and then still seems low.
Yeah, it does it and I
think peanut mentioned it.
I know I got a lot of guys
in DFS calm for the saints.
This Tampa Bay team is just dog shit.
All right.
Is there not a narrative where it's
like there's a narrative for sure that a
Tampa Bay, Gerald McCoy makes a couple
plays. They got defensive touchdown.
I,
I randomly have a soft spot for
Fitzsimmons but I don't think it's Patrick
Fitzpatrick. Sorry. I love
that guy. He went to Harvard.
Ryan as they bring up every other time.
It's this guy went to Hamad.
He is a is a smack.
Nice accent was horrible. I'm going
to take the saints minus 10 air. I,
part of me would like to take a
divisional game and take the big number,
but I'm just so against
this Tampa Bay team.
I just don't see it man.
Why? I just don't see it.
And I think uh, they're loaded. Tampa Bay,
Cameron Bray,
Oj Howard Godwin.
Evan's the Sean Jackson. Yeah, they have,
they have skilled position player
running backs. A bit of a question often.
Some wine, a little bit of a
question. The defense has players.
This just strikes me as the kind of game,
kind of like the buffalo one where maybe
I come after two of these spots and I
hit one but I,
I one of these two teams is not covering.
Now the thing I'll say about the saints,
the saints have the offense
to manage this and that.
That would be my hesitation and I this,
this is by no means a game that I'm
looking to play. But again, 10 points,
it's a of points.
I'm
going to take the dog. Aww. Wow.
You are extra chocky today. Sean,
what do you mean? Just hoping
that the uh, the league continues.
Like last year I took the 40
niners catching six and a half.
I took the eagles again.
Another contrary in play for some reason.
Well you're,
you're certainly on the public side and
this one 80% almost 80% on the saints.
It is early in the week though. So some
of these numbers don't mean that much.
Next up, Shaun Hughston
Mellow Brian, a little,
a little big brother game here heading
up to New England where Belichick and the
Patriots are laying six and a half
minus two 70 plus two 10 to 20 for the
Texans. 51 is the total
highest total on the board.
As you were mentioning mentioning before,
uh,
Texans are actually getting some love
right and everyone's kind of talking about
how getting some love,
I mean listen now that now that gambling
is legal and a lot of states and
fantasy football and that I think fantasy
football is having to even a bigger
impact in this line plot. I mean everyone
has a hard offer to Sean Watson. Again,
great guy, great player, but
he was three and three, right?
Like this is a tough spot to go into
New England and beat the Patriots coming
off a loss we mentioned with bill,
but Bella check is coming off a loss.
I think the Patriots perpetually
find motivation and the,
I think that's as much as
it pains me to say this,
I think that's kind of their greatest
asset is they've in this five super bowl
run,
they found ways to stay motivated if they
don't get complacent and I don't think
they're going to be complacent at home
opening day against the Texans and Bella
check just doesn't get beat by his
assistance. Like it just doesn't happen.
He doesn't, I know we're talking
about a spread here. We're not,
we're not picking games straight up
like uh, Lee Corso and those guys,
they are on the college game day.
Yeah. Someone, someone tweeted out,
they go wow people and
wonder why they're waiting.
Wondering why the ratings are
down. They're picking, yeah.
Like 28 point spreads straight up and
the acting like they have some sort of
insight. This is a, you know,
this is going to be a 31 17 game.
I,
I as much as you could make a case for
a Houston's defense and the fact that
they're completely healthy and how they
could kind of wreck the shop of New
England. I'll say this about New England.
Look what they did against the eagles.
The Eagles hadn't really could defense
going into that super bowl and they gave
Brady a bunch of time.
I mean obviously Brady dropped a wide
open pass and Brady fumbled the ball away
when he,
when they did get to him
and they basically made that
one play that they needed
to beat them.
But New England schemed up a good game
and I just can't imagine Bellacheck
having the whole off season stewing about
that super bowl loss and he's going to
lose to a guy he used to be his boss.
That's a tough scenario for me to
swallow. And I mean, you know, we had
a doctor,
we had an actual doctor on talking about
the coming back from the knee injury.
And I think regardless of how
well, how, if he can play or not,
he's not going to be 100% and
with a guy like the Sean Watson,
I think you have to worry that,
you know,
part of what makes him great
is his ability to do great
things and he does a lot
of those great things with his leg.
So will that be the same?
Will the offensive line hold up?
You can say a lot of the same
things about the patriots,
the differences that Belichick and Brady,
I'm a track record of doing more
with less. I may be wrong here,
but I'm not going to come out of
the gate going against the Patriots,
especially when I,
when I can lay less than a touchdown
against the team that I think, you know,
look, here's, think he'd be a really good
team and drop this game by 17 points.
So I'm with you, Sean. We're, we're
both on New England, lock it up.
Last of the early camps and maybe another
game that none of us will give a shit
about.
Tennessee.
The Tennessee Titans head down in Miami
where Miami is a two point home dog.
45 is the total.
I didn't see him money on it.
They do not have a money line
up on this over at my bookie,
45 is the total. Sean, you got a,
you got to look at, you got to
look at Miami early in the season,
just like we're going to talk about in
a couple of games with another team.
Early season home field advantage,
I think you could apply
temperature and humidity,
humidity and someone's gonna ease.
You know you're going to be like,
well Tennessee, it's humid
there. It's not Miami.
Marcus Mariota is not good.
Why am I the only guy who
sees that and I fucking crazy
and it's another Bella check disciple who,
I mean these guys don't,
Bella check doesn't let them do like
he lets them do stuff but he doesn't
actually like share the intelligence.
So none of these guys
have really succeeded.
I had a Marcus Mariota had more
interceptions and touchdowns last year.
Why are we still talking about this guy
like he's a franchise quarterback cause
he's the ruins touchdown to himself.
That was awesome.
And yet he was in a great situation.
Andy Reid in the playoffs,
they found a way to fuck that up.
If Travis Kelsey doesn't have
his brain pushed in. Seriously,
that was the turning point. That was
the turning point to the game. This,
this Tennessee team, Marcus
ferry road is not a winner. I,
I really don't like Miami,
but I like Miami and the spot Ryan,
we talked about how September's the new
preseason football and to not overreact.
Our Buddy, uh, bill burr
even said it. Oh, week one,
everyone's getting his lock was that
week one. Everyone's going to be,
all the talking heads are going to be
fired up and making broad crazy statements
for the season. And I think the
fact that Miami will win this game,
we'll win it by a decent margin and
then all of a sudden become the sleeper
darling,
I think will eventually fall off.
I know it's kind of crazy to predict
that, but I, I like mammy and the spot,
but I don't like the dolphins
for the season. Yeah, I think I,
I think I agree with everything
you said. I, I,
I don't think the dolphins,
it was surprising for me to
see that 65% of the money.
I'm a dolphins again early in the week.
This is not a heavily back game,
so the number doesn't mean a ton to me,
but surprise to see that and
I mean this is,
I don't, I don't know. I
got to see Tennessee do
something honestly like Miami.
I know you're low on Miami,
I'm hiring Miami, but I think,
I just think this is one of
the games that they get as a,
when they shouldn't be a two point
dog to Tennessee that that's,
that's really what this
comes down to Sean.
Great.
Next up early.
Oh afternoon kicks here on the West Coast,
Kansas City heads to Los Angeles,
Sean and the soccer stadium where the
chargers are laying three and a half
points minus one 85 on the money line
plus one 55 for the new look chiefs 48 the
total you back in the homes
and as a first real start.
Yeah,
I keep going back and forth on this one
because this is another one. Uh,
Kansas City is, this is a very, uh,
like kind of the stereotypical
pros versus joes game.
The Publix on Sandy Arab. I said, there
it is. The public's on Los Angeles,
Sean Sandy Bay
and the pros are on Kansas City.
This number's probably too big.
Yeah, it is a divisional game.
I don't love. It's going to feel a little
bit like, Oh, I'm game. Here's, here's,
here's where I'm looking at of this game.
I really like the over.
That's what I really like in this game
because I think Kansas City's defense
can't stop anyone and I think the
chargers will put up a lot of points.
What I'm scared about is Andy read
having a bunch of time to scheme up some
stuff that uh, I think we'll
put the chargers, you know,
we'll fuck the chargers up
and also the charges are just
such a snake bitten franchise.
But at the end of the day,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go chargers minus three
and a half. I've debated this a lot.
I just moved my pick on the spreadsheet
charges minus three and a half.
And that's because Joey Bosa,
Melvin Ingram against Patrick,
my homes and Patrick my homes.
I think we'll end up being a
good quarterback in this league.
However you watch any, any of his early
stuff, he's turnover prone, right?
He'll give you a couple of big plays
and that's again, why I like the over.
I think if you look at uh,
a fantasy defense,
I think there's a defensive touchdown
possible for this Los Angeles chargers
team.
And I think that'll end up
being the difference and
why they covered the spread.
If it gets close, obviously there's
a chance Casey wins out, right?
Because of how snake bitten this chargers
team is and Kansas City has plenty of
weapons. So there's definitely a case
to be made for the chiefs. But I'll,
I'll lean
chargers here. Yeah, I mean again,
this is there another team where they
then this defense got so much better last
year they brought in the kid from Florida
state cane to play say they have the
pass rush and uh, but they, they,
they struggled to stop the run.
And if you were to highlight a weakness
of this defense last year it was
stopping the run and you know, they, they,
the teams that we're able to kind of
beat him up and run on them and you, you,
you take Bosa out of the game.
Yeah.
And I think as much as I
don't like the chiefs, this,
how does, how much does Andy
Reid actually commit to the run?
I think he know he is just,
he's just sitting there with
the on waiting unleased homes.
Well you haven't even mentioned
the coaching disadvantage
that answered your own
has read is one 70% he's seven
and three straight up Sean.
We've been rolling though.
College football, we're, we're,
we forgot about the spreads in the NFL.
Like you can't just throw a three and
a half and a divisional game where you
don't have any home field advantage.
You'd be like, that's cool.
I know my homes is going to
turn the turn the ball over,
but it's the NFL like this. We're not
going to see all these crazy blowouts.
This is going to sound really bad when
we just see a whole bunch of, but Ryan,
Ryan, Ryan, the exception is your,
I think if you take the chiefs I
respect that pick in that plight,
but you're underestimating how dog shit.
The Kansas City chiefs defense
in particular. The secondary is,
I don't, I hate doing the double
negative, but I don't disagree Sean.
I just don't,
we,
we spent the whole preseason talking
about their lack of a home field and how
many chiefs fans are going to be showing
up to this game and I like the chargers
that have a chance to win this game.
I just can't lay three and a half.
They're going to miss a kick. They're
going to do something that fucks it up.
Give me Kansas City plus the points
here. Okay. Just update Eric Berry.
This is from coach Andy Reid. He's day
to day. It's not looking good. Oh No.
The chiefs turned over their
entire secondary shedding.
Six cornerbacks from last year and plan
to start Ron Parker at one of the two
safety spots.
Eric Berry's not going to play from my,
from my knowledge.
And I think that'll be a big passing
day for Philip and company. So look,
start Keenan Allen.
I mean if you play in Tonio gates,
you I think crazy, crazier stuff. I think
you target this game for DFS period.
And I didn't say DFS is the Er over
as the play in this game. See I,
I'll go the other way.
I think it's so obviously an over.
I'm gonna take the under. I think I, I'm
telling you man, like I just want to,
I want to be contrarian for
these early this, this week.
While you're not very contrarian around,
I guess you do have the giants of the
bucks. I'll give you that. And Buffalo.
Yeah, I, I have some unpopular
pics. I don't feel, I can't, I,
the chargers are definitely the, the,
the, the public and more popular side.
So I have it there too. Next up, Sean,
one 25 kick here on the west coast.
Seattle.
I guess they're all, Thomas is
playing. We don't know either way.
Either way.
Russell,
the love muscle will lead the Seahawks
down into Denver or case Kanombe in the
Broncos are laying three minus
one 50 on the money line.
Seattle plus one 30 43 is the total right.
We've been talking,
this came up enough.
They had Denver minus three add
home Emmanuel Sanders case keen.
Emma like that option obviously
for all Thomas plays and is 100%.
Well I guess we'll see.
But Denver at home early
is a huge advantage. Again,
the collective bargaining
agreement doesn't allow
these guys to quite get their
conditioning right. And uh, I just,
Seattle probably not a great team.
Maybe.
Maybe they pull this out cause they do
have the best player probably on the
field. Russel Wilson. But I feel
good about Denver Minister. Yeah.
Not much to say here. Uh, I, I, I like
Russell Wilson to have a good year.
Statistically,
I hopefully bald and we can stay healthy.
I just think this is a bad spot.
I think the defense is going to struggle.
There's no way Earl Thomas, this is
just going to play right? May I guess,
who knows? Who knows? There's no way he
can be ready to play at altitude. Yeah.
At altitude.
I do worry about case Keenum but I,
I liked the receivers they put around him.
I liked the Royce Freeman kid.
I think they're going to,
I think they could do something on offense
and I know they're going to be good
at defense. So Denver is very
obvious to me. Shawn and I,
and I don't think we mentioned
this, Sean, but these lines,
these are the free roll
football contest lines.
So if you're hearing the
number and you like the side,
go sign up contest dot
sports gambling podcast.com.
And if you want to bet these lines,
go to my bookie that Aig promocode,
SCP or STP reload.
Get in the contest,
get into awesome. You're
not, you're not going to.
Me and Sean are going to slay everyone.
I'm predicting a top two finish for us.
I love it. Next up Shawn, another one,
25 kicked Dallas and the cowgirls
Jason traveling with his shine box.
I'll go home and get your fucking shine
box. Does he checked the shine box?
Is it carry on?
Uh,
Dallas is heading the Carolina and to
take on your boy Cam Newton as minus
Carolina's minus three minus
one 45 on the money line.
One 25 for the cowboys,
42 and a half.
This is an awfully low total. Um,
it, it, it's interestingly low
Carolina roles.
Carolina roles and I don't
like Cam Newton again.
I was the one who came up with Sham
Newton. Don't try and steal that from me.
That is intellectual property
over time. I like how you get
more and more aggressive at,
you're claiming of the nickname sham noon,
Dallas name one matchup that
the cowboys have better. Listen,
Luke Keekley is healthy.
He hasn't gotten a concussion yet at Kara.
Dallas has no one to catch a pass.
Carolina's just gonna Stack the box. Yeah.
They have so much more weapons on
the offensive side. Cam Newton,
as much as I don't like him personally
is a better quarterback is a playmaker.
Why would this be even on a neutral field?
I will say this,
the potential strength of the
Dallas defense is those linebackers.
And if those linebackers can cover the
combination of Greg Olson and Christian
McCaffrey, it becomes an
interesting game. But again,
Dallas is offense is or their strength
is their offensive line and they're not
going to get that same push with
all the injuries. The classic,
it's a three point spread. It probably,
I guess it could be, uh, you know,
to me,
Carolina,
Dallas is closer to three and
a half then chargers chiefs.
So I will lay the points with
Carolina. Um, not, not to mention,
I just, you know, we got to see,
I mean we need to see the cowboys
offensive line do something too.
So it's cowboys could roll,
but I'm taking Carolinas,
came on Austin starting receiver.
Look,
someone has to catch the ball.
I don't know if you've watched the
NFL in the past 30 years. Allen Hurns,
Allen Hurns that that's the
DFS guy this week. Sean,
last of the late afternoon kicks,
early afternoon here on the west coast.
The Washington to
professional football team,
they had to Arizona for Bradford is
not a fucking franchise quarterback.
Arizona is very excited to say Redskins.
Uh,
Arizona minus one 44 is the total.
I'm very torn here. Sean. Yeah, I know.
I'm the same way because Sam Bradford,
as much as he sucks,
he has randomly showed up at
a dome in a week one home.
Um, but I, I'm going to feed them.
I actually think David Johnson,
we'll have a good game.
So I do like that on the DFS side,
but I think the skins pull this one out
as a, I'm not super high on the skins,
but Alex Smith,
and again,
sometimes you just don't
have to overthink it.
Alex Smith is a guy who wins games and
Sam Bradford is the guy who loses games
to Alex Smith 88 62 and one as a starter.
I know you're not going to
look at some crazy trends,
but I think they have a
very conservative game plan.
I'm really worried about Arizona's
defense as far as what they can trot out
there,
especially in week one.
And I think David Johnson
again has it has a good game,
especially from Ppr because he's just
going to get a shitload of targets and
maybe that's enough.
Maybe he breaks some but gun to my
head or I'm going to take the, uh,
the Redskins here
mean I
guess so. Sure. Arizona could be bad.
I think that's the consensus is
Arizona is going to be pretty bad but,
but it is Sam Bradford and it,
it is the first game of the season and
he is healthy and he has had good games
in the first game even
as recently as last year.
So, uh, I don't know why.
I don't know what's wrong with you Sean.
Cause you're,
you're backing Gruden on the road
anchored and baby Jay Gruden.
Yeah, sure. Alex Smith
was great with Andy Reid,
but we've seen quarterbacks leave Andy
read before and it's not so pretty.
No one's really talking about that.
That is not a narrative. Right.
When you go for, when
you leave, when you go,
when you go from a quarterback guru
to a self proclaimed quarterback guru.
I Dunno if that's the best thing.
Look,
I don't think the Redskins
are going to be horrible.
I think this is just a
tough spot and I like,
dare I say Bradford to
have a decent game here.
Can me the cardinals minus
one chigger not a great coach,
but possibly better than Stephen Wilkes.
We don't know.
He was a good d coordinator
for the panthers, right?
What? Right. It was all right.
The giants wanted I,
there were rumors that giants wanted
to hire him and I was very happy they
didn't. They got a Shermer.
All right, John Prime time,
Sunday night football bears,
packers, Lambeau field,
Greenbay minus seven and a half minus
three 45 on the money line plus two 75 for
the bears.
47 and a half is the total.
That's a lot of fucking points, right?
A little too big. You see this news,
Sean,
what the rams aggressively,
aggressively went after.
Clear clue Mac. Uh,
right before the Paris traded for him am
I don't know where they're getting all
this money.
Did they get to some sort of tax exemption
when they moved to Los Angeles? Um,
that, that would have been pretty
interesting. But yeah, the bears.
Is Matt going to be a difference maker?
Listen, I don't think that bears
defense. Was that bad to begin with?
And if you throw Kahleel backin yeah, I
think they're going to be better. I think,
uh,
I think Nagy decent coach,
he has a scheme that they
haven't seen before. Again,
you're going against Green Bay at home,
so I'm not taking them to win.
Probably not. But yeah, Chicago
can keep this a one score game.
Why do we,
why isn't it naggy going to be good?
Like why isn't somatically
going to be good?
Does that automatically
going to be good Ryan?
But I'm predicting that he learned how
to scheme up quarterbacks in the same way
that Doug Peterson came from the Andy Re
coaching tree and went to Philadelphia
and and took a rookie quarterback
and developed a great system for him,
which helped lead them ultimately
to a super bowl championship.
I think the Arizona or sorry,
I think that Nagy can help
to ski a and they have some,
they have some play makers around him.
I think Jordan Howard, solid player.
I think he could have a big season
Terico and may still get a few catches in
there.
Trey Burton,
again,
it's the kind of guy you want
in a Andy Reid type system.
I think all that leads to a,
a competitive bears team and I
think the team is excited, right?
The bears are jacked up. Listen,
Green Bay at home and prime time.
It's tough to go against some shit up,
but I think seven, I think this is a game,
so I'll take seven and a half. They're
trapping you with the hook, Sean,
because you know what still true.
Very sure it happened.
Mitchell [inaudible] still sucks.
Yeah, I know. Why has that changed? We,
we did this for five months,
no football and all of,
I did have John Fox.
All of a sudden,
Mitch,
I washed and playing college. Dude. He
said two full years of playing football.
Lay the points. Give me Aaron
Rodgers in total feu mode. Come on,
do this at 10 point game, you can see
it. So it's a possibility. I mean,
if someone teased green bay
down from seven and a half,
have minus one and a half.
That's not a bad teas.
But I'm finishing strong
with some favorite Sean.
Next up the jets on the early, the
stupid early Monday night football game.
We'll rex rex Ryan be calling this game.
No, he will not. The Jerry's Rex Ryan,
I thought he was,
wasn't calling mine somewhere.
The jets had to Detroit
where Matt Stafford and the
lions are minus seven minus
two 80 on the money line
plus two 30 for the jets.
45 is the total Shaun Stafford beats
bad teams that he does what Willy Cover?
No, he will not. Wow. Save
Your Sam and the New York jets.
I liked this jet steam, rookie
quarterback, rookie quarterback,
youngest quarterback to start,
but
uh, younger, uh, to start like a
Monday night game or I don't know,
whatever the stat was. He's,
he's only 21 not 22 yet.
The guy has composure in the pocket.
I like what I've seen at a Sam Darnold.
They have skill players,
right?
They have
skilled players.
I think their defense is good enough.
Tadpoles,
Anne. Okay. Coach he is to
me is the jet Superbowl.
I love fading them next week on
a short week with Sam Darnold,
but I think same. Donald makes enough
place to keep them in this game.
This is tough,
Sean,
because Detroit is the kind of team
that you would want to fade when they're
laying seven points.
Yes.
It is a strangely early kick.
Will everyone be there?
Yeah. It's Detroit, so no one has a job.
Is that what you're trying to insinuate?
Oh, c'mon. Right. All right.
You make enemies not booming,
but I think if you're going to a lions
game, you're, you're available at six,
10:00 PM on a Monday.
Is it six 10?
Aren't they eastern or maybe they're
seven 10 the right on that edge.
I think it's seven 10 either way they're
going to be at the game or whoever's
going to show up to the game. I, I like
Sam Darnold here. You saw it with Wentz.
You saw it with some
other rookie quarterbacks.
There's an early window before they kind
of hit that rookie wall before enough
tape gets out on them were guys who can
play in the league really thrive and
they ended up winning because
they make a bunch of crazy plays.
He'll make some plays at this feet.
I'll kind of be playing above his head.
He'll kind of crashed down to earth,
but I could see Sam Darnold
getting out to a hot start.
I just don't see, this is another
game where I'm just inclined to take,
it's hard for me to to
take chalk on Monday night,
but that's where I think I want to go.
Gimme gimme Stafford and
the fighting lions. Okay.
Staff.
I mean, come on dude. You're
the rookie is going to get it.
It's a dome road. I
just don't, I don't see,
I don't see him being
successful right away.
I think there's too many stories and
too much about his inconsistencies.
I know he's looked good in the pre season,
but this is one of those like not so
fast moments. Last game of the week,
Sean let her rep the
awkwardly late game on on the,
on the east coast,
the rams,
they head down to Oakland
where John Ruetten. Yeah.
It depends which way you're looking at it.
They had up to Oakland where
Oakland and Jon Gruden art,
four and a half point
home dogs. Sean, this,
this line opened I think in a pick to
put it in perspective and it's just been
bet by the rams over and over and over.
All Rams money.
96% Sean,
96%
Aye.
We were, I mean there's no way
96% of the monies on one side.
It's gone from pick to four and a
half. Yeah. Do you like the Raiders?
Four and a half points in the
NFL is a lot. I'm just so,
I so much want to take,
I want to say I want to Fade Jan grid.
If John Gruden they come out and they
look amazing and their defense plays great
in spite of the fact of
being Natika defense and the,
and then getting rid of Cleo Mack. I'll
eat some crow, fill me up with a big bowl,
bull crow. But uh, I think,
I think the rams can handle Todd Gurley
who's tackling Todd Gurley on this rams
defense
conference road game.
The lines moved four and a half points
and I still that that's how bad this is.
Like
plenty of warnings as far as why
you shouldn't take this. But uh,
yeah, give me the ransom
at it's four and a half.
I just don't see it with Oakland. I
just don't see it. Koons coming in.
She changing the culture of firing
video coordinators who've been there for
years and Kinda reminds me of chip Kelly.
But I don't think they,
I don't think he has the athletes
and we're the brain. I like,
I like Wade Phillips and that defense
versus John Group. Right. So if the,
the raters do win the game,
it's by them. And I just
don't see how that happens.
He's already not looked smart.
It's just he's come off
really poorly. Yeah. Sorry,
I'm just fading,
you know.
I'm sorry if I want to feed him and Hugh
Jackson Week one. Although I, I would,
I will lie. Tie Rod almost had me,
he almost had me almost sucked.
The Iran is a time.
Yeah,
that's right Ryan. It is time for
our lock dog and tees of course.
Brought to you by my book. Eat Daddy
g Kramer. I'll give you the honors
lock. Denver. Yes. Pretty obvious.
I grabbed this at two earlier in the
summer. Uh, I still like it a three.
I think this Seattle team,
perhaps a lot of questions and not,
not the pass rush you want to see
week one when you have a questionable
offensive line for my dog,
Sean.
I didn't, I don't feel like I took a
lot of dogs in that actual like, oh,
they could win this game range and I'm
not going to give you the eagles or the
giants. So I'll get, I'll,
I'll throw the complete like this.
This is the game and I believe we were
out in Vegas together, Sean, when the, uh,
the saints were hosting the rams and
we were sitting near a guy who had a
$10,000 wager and,
and w on like a minus 500 bet and lost.
Yeah,
it was pretty awesome. Not recommended
in the NFL taken minus 500 Tampa Bay.
Wow.
Strange feeling about this one.
Super strange feeling about this one.
Uh, and I, and I just like, I honestly,
I was going to throw out the giants,
but you were gonna you would
give me shit for that. No,
I mean if you're scared of me giving you
shit and yeah, no, no, no, no. I, I'm,
I'm going to throw out,
I'm going to go to a cop.
I'm going to go big week one and give you
a four to one dog all and everyone can
come back and stroke it. I will
say this, I will say this survival,
like I'm not getting near, I'm not getting
near the saints and the survivor pool.
I'm not teasing the saints this week.
That came worries me and a from its
speaking of teas is Sean first up,
bring New England down to minus 600
or two minus a half, right? Yup.
Step one,
step two
bring,
bring Detroit down to minus one because
we know what Stafford does against bad
teams.
He just wins.
Step three you bring green bay
down to one and a half. No Way.
You, no way. This goes in here.
No Way. This goes wrong for you.
It will not go wrong.
It's too too well.
I feel like getting the
Detroit angle in there.
I'm going to have to
sweat it to Monday and I,
but that's my t's New England minus a
half Detroit minus one green minus one
and a half. All right. I'm
on the clock. Carolina.
My Loc so many.
I mean I love feeding the cowboys,
but so much just the matchups
alone panthers all the way.
No one's going to listen to this lock
this week because you're going against the
cowboys. Well, I mean I,
well that's their loss run.
I Agree Jeff.
Just letting you know
the jets plus two 30.
I think they shock the world Monday night.
Shit gets crazy in Detroit.
Gimme the jets and save your Sam my teeth.
If you're Sam,
you just love saying that.
It is fun to say I'll take a Baltimore
down to minus two. That's good.
I will take New England
down to minus a half.
That's the one that's
going to fuck both and uh,
he kicked me Washington up to
seven mm smart adjustment there.
Shown what you see what he did.
He took it through three key numbers.
Exactly right.
Exactly.
Thank you for participating in the
sports together pocket. Oh Man.
You should remind people once.
One more time Sean. One more time.
Go to contest Dad's sports scaling
podcasts that come to sign up for the free
roll football podcast presented by odds.
What?
Free Roll football contest.
What did I say?
You can't screw up the name of
the contest. What did I say?
You said the free roll football
podcast. Oh, free roll football content.
Thank you for participating
in the sports gambling.
[inaudible] presented by odd shark end,
the sports gambling podcast network.
And for sports gaming podcasts. I'm Sean
second the money green and he is Ryan.
John, continue to rate review, share.
Keep us on the charts.
And a special thanks to a
zero eight Hokey Benner,
very entertaining podcast.
Five stars.
Just wanted to give me a shout out
cause fellow fellow Hokey Sean Cramer.
Let it ride.
[inaudible].